scenes like these are hurting dozens of
families in argentina's capital
this man on a stretcher ingested cocaine
that's suspected of having been laced
with poison
authorities say hundreds of people were
sold to the contaminated drug in recent
days it can cause severe breathing
problems and even heart attacks less
than an hour after being ingested
dozens of people have died
outside hospital relatives wait
and pray
i lived with an addict all my life
now my son is an addict when i lock him
up in the house he jumps from our second
floor window to buy drugs
nearby mass is held for those who died
and for those who are still in hospital
others are thankful they survived
i was with my friends earlier in the
week and i took some cocaine i felt a
stomach ache and a headache my vision
became blurry and i began to throw up
then i started to throw up blood i got
scared and came to the hospital for help
the low-income neighborhood of lomermosa
has been affected the most
authorities are investigating many lies
of inquiry
among them whether drug gangs spiked
batches of rivals cocaine to weaken
competition
arrests have been made and police say
more will follow
some people who took the contaminated
cocaine suffered respiratory problems
but they didn't go to hospital or reach
out for help because of stigma and
discrimination
possession and personal consumption of
cocaine has been decriminalized in
argentina since 2009
but transporting and selling the drug is
still illegal
authorities are trying to find the
source of the tainted cocaine to remove
it from circulation
they're also urging people who purchased
the drug recently to not ingest it
but even after the warning they fear the
death toll will rise
katya lopez al jazeera